in the indian state of manipur you will  find kaipulumja national park  the world's only floating wildlife  sanctuary  kaiba lumjao comprises over 15 square  miles of rich biodiverse wetlands and  includes loktak lake the largest  freshwater lake in northern india  the park is known for patches and rings  of biomass that float on the surface of  the wetlands  the floating vegetation called fundy  thrives in the park creating a home for  humans and animals alike  [Music]  the endangered sangai a subspecies of  brow antler deer are only found in the  park  they have been called the binding soul  between humans and nature  the sangai was believed to be nearing  extinction in the 1950s but thanks to  aggressive conservation efforts their  numbers have steadily increased to more  than 200.  still relatively unknown outside the  region  kaibulum zhao national park is truly one  of india's hidden gems  [Music]  you